(electronic music)
- No, no cool intro, no fancy music.
I just want to explain
inflation in six minutes.
I have a degree in economics.
I spent years trying to understand this.
(ominous music)
so let's see if I can boil it down.
What is inflation?
Why is it rising?
Why are people worried?
And what do interest
rates have to do with it?
- The Federal Reserve is
raising the interest rate.
- [Reporter] Fed is set
to raise interest rate.
- Highest inflation in 40 years.
- Listen, I know that I make long videos.
I'm into nuance, I'm into backstory.
Well, this isn't that.
This is quick.
("quick" echoing)
No, really, this is quick.
Let's go.
(rapid electronic music)
Wait, wait, wait, rewind.
Hold on one second.
Before we start the
timer, I need to tell you
that I was going to do an ad read
in the middle of the explanation.
Like I was gonna stop the
explanation and do an ad read,
but I realized I want this
to be an uninterrupted
six-minute explanation, so I'll even take
out the YouTube ads that are on it
so that it can be uninterrupted.
But for now, I need to
thank today's sponsor
because it's literally my
job, it's how I get paid.
Thank you, BetterHelp
for supporting this video
and my channel generally.
BetterHelp is customized online
therapy that offers video,
phone, or even live chat
sessions with your therapist.
So you don't have to see anyone on camera
if you don't want to.
Therapy is a giant part
of my life, been doing it
for several years now,
and I believe in it.
But I know that finding
a therapist is hard
and cumbersome and BetterHelp
is trying to change that.
It's all on the internet.
All you have to do is take a quiz
and they link you up with a therapist.
They have a giant network
of over 20,000 licensed therapists.
You can be talking to
someone in like 48 hours.
And if your therapist isn't a good fit,
you can change for free,
which is a huge deal.
So join the two million plus
people who are taking charge
of their mental health with BetterHelp.
You can even get 10% off your first month
if you go to the link in my description,
betterhelp.com/Johnny Harris.
Do us both a favor and click on that link
and go see if therapy
can improve your life
as much as it has mine.
Thank you, BetterHelp,
for supporting this video.
Okay, the ad is over, let's
start the clock up again
and see if I can do this
explanation in six minutes.
Here we go.
- Okay, first up, the simplest definition.
Inflation is when there is
more money in the economy
than stuff to spend it on.
But if you're like me, the
simplest definition never does
it for you.
So let's try this.
Imagine a village that has
one market where people buy
all of their stuff, their
food, their clothes,
but one day the government shows up
because they're worried about
the economy of this village.
So they tell the people
that if they want to take
out a loan, they're gonna make sure
that the banks will not charge
them a high interest rate.
They want to encourage the
people to take out loans
and spend money.
Oh, and they also drop
off a giant pile of cash
for everyone in the village.
And everyone in the
village is like, "Sweet,
I'm feeling pretty rich."
Villagers now are going to
their market and they're buying
way more stuff.
Many of them have been eyeing
the fancy electric bike
in the market that before
they couldn't justify.
But now they totally can
because they have all this new money.
The store owner's like, "Sweet.
this is great for business."
But he's running out of bikes.
In fact, he's running out of everything
because now all of these
people have extra money
and they're buying way
more than they used to.
The store owner is like, "I can't keep up
with all this demand,
I should raise prices."
And that is inflation.
But the village is all
of us and the market is
the entire economy.
When there's extra money floating around
and people wanna spend it faster
than businesses can make stuff,
then all of the businesses
in all of the industries
raise their prices.
And that is inflation.
It's a natural part of the economy.
It's kind of a good thing in
small doses because it means
that the economy is growing.
And it's why movie tickets
used to be 25 cents
and now they're like $15.
And slowly over time, it's fine.
Okay, let's go back to the
village and see what happens
if we keep going at this rate.
The store owner has now
doubled his prices on bikes.
The interest rate is super low so he takes
out a loan to build a new
factory to make bikes.
This is good, he's growing a business.
But the government money
eventually runs out
and his prices are still double.
But now the store owner
has no one to come buy
all of his new bikes.
And now he has this
factory and more employees,
but no customers.
He has to shut down the
factory, lay off everyone,
and slowly start lowering his prices.
This is called recession.
When COVID shut down the world,
governments gave us money,
free money.
They're like don't panic
and hoard all your money,
instead spend and borrow
and keep the economy going.
Here in the U.S., they
literally sent us $3,200 checks.
They gave 600 bucks a week
to people who were unemployed
for months and months and months.
They gave subsidies to people with kids.
They increased spending on food stamps.
I mean, trillions and trillions of dollars
of stimulus money.
This was vital aid to people in need,
but even people who didn't lose a job got
a check in the mail.
It was free money for
everyone and we spent it.
- I just picked up myself a new bike.
- [Reporter] Demand is
up across the country.
- It's time to grind, Peloton.
- We all just got these big
checks from the government
during a pandemic.
We're like YOLO, I'm buying a
boat or a Peloton or whatever.
- [Man] Pokemon cards.
- [Man] There's Netflix.
- [Woman] Fortnite.
- [Man] A new Motor.
- [Woman] Peloton.
- [Woman] Good soak in a hot tub.
- [Woman] Animal Crossing.
- Push it out a little bit so it--
- No, don't you dare!
- But pair all this new
spending with the fact
that the pandemic also made
it harder for factories
and ships and retailers
to get us all this stuff.
- Supply chain issue.
- Global supply chain.
- Supply chain.
- Supply.
- Chain.
- So now you have an
economy where people have
way more money than normal
and they're ready to spend it,
but the economy can't get
them stuff fast enough.
So what do businesses do with
all this insane new demand?
They raise prices all at the same time
and that is inflation.
(exhaling)
I feel like we're getting
this at this point.
But what do interest rates
have to do with all this?
- Raising the interest rate.
- Interest rate.
- Or the Fed?
- Fed.
- Federal Reserve.
- The Federal Reserve.
- Most countries have a
central bank, the puppet master
of the economy, the bank of
all banks for that country.
But it's not like a normal
bank that stores our money
and then lends it out and
collects interest to make profit.
That's what a normal private bank does.
The central bank, which
we call the Fed here
in the U.S. is run by the government.
So their job is to set
the rules or policies
that all the other banks have to follow.
And the central bank
isn't motivated by profit,
but rather their job is to
babysit the economy to keep
it growing, to make sure people have jobs,
to make sure that prices
don't fluctuate too much
so that we can keep growing
nicely, no slow down,
no recession, that is
what the Fed is there for.
But seriously, the Fed
is like a puppet master
and we are the puppets
and it's kind of creepy.
They pull strings in the
economy to get us to spend
our money in a certain
way, which in turn affects
how much businesses raise
or drop their prices.
And guess what?
It totally works.
One of the strings that they have to pull
in the economy is called
the interest rate.
Wanna borrow money to buy a car or a house
or expand your business?
You're gonna be way more likely to do that
if you only have to pay
2% interest on that loan
as opposed to like 6%.
Lower interest rates equal people
and businesses wanna
borrow and spend money.
So during the pandemic,
the central bank was like
we need everyone to spend money.
So they lowered the interest
rate and people borrowed
and people spent, and it totally worked.
We're like freaking puppets.
So a lower interest rate
helped stimulate the economy.
But once again, we're in this
same place where there's now
too much money to borrow and
spend and not enough goods
and services to spend it on.
So what do businesses
do all at the same time?
They raise prices to
meet all this new demand
all at the same time and now
your money is worth less.
And that is inflation.
- [Reporter] Home prices
rising at their highest rate.
- [Man] Astronomical bidding war.
- Are going up.
- By nearly 24%.
- So that's what's happening right now.
All the prices are rising
kind of at the same time.
What that means is that
your hundred dollar bill is
now worth 8% less than it was last year.
Like the same money is worth less
because your purchasing
power just got diluted.
And imagine if that keeps happening?
Like instead of 8% it's 50%?
Now your hundred dollar bill
is worth what $50 used to be.
And that's when people start to freak out.
And our economy that's built
on human psychology starts
to falter and we fall into
a recession or a depression,
even, if it gets real
bad, which is exactly
what the Fed is built to avoid.
So they're back to pulling their strings
and they've started raising rates.
- The Federal Reserve is
raising interest rates.
- The Federal Reserve taking
action to try and curb
rising inflation.
- They're gently raising the
interest rate to cool down
all of this hardcore
spending and borrowing,
see if they can steer
the ship back on course.
And let's hope it works.
Okay, did we do it?
Did we do, did we do it in the time period
that I promised I would?
- [Nick] I have no idea.
- We'll find out.
(jazz music)
Okay, last thing I wanna say
is a thing that didn't make it
into my little inflation explainer,
but a few years ago when I worked at Vox,
I went to Venezuela and
Columbia to do a borders series.
I saw inflation up close and
personal because in Venezuela,
inflation got so out of
control and they couldn't,
the Fed, the puppet
master couldn't figure out
how to get it back in control
that their money became worth nothing.
The prices went up so high
that their money became
basically worthless.
You needed like a pile
of cash to buy bread.
So what they started doing
is they started using
the currency itself to make things.
I visited this guy on
the street who was making
purses and bags and sculptures out of cash
because it was worth more as
a raw material than it was
as money, as a currency, which is insane.
That's a very extreme
version of inflation.
It's happened in several
countries that have done this.
We're not in that situation,
even close to that situation,
but it's an example
of just how tenuous modern economies are.
They're not pegged to gold or whatever.
They're pegged to a
bunch of humans believing
that this stuff is worth something
and it can quickly go off the rails.
So I thought I'd share
that little, fun thing
that is more documented
in the Vox borders episode
that you can go watch on
the Vox YouTube channel.
So that's all I've got.
Thank you all for being here
and I think you should check
out, if you want to color
your videos or your photos,
I have LUTs and presets
that you can use to
color correct your stuff.
I also have a storytelling course
on Bright Trip where I
talk about my methodology
for visual storytelling
with Nathaniel Drew.
I think that's sort of it,
all the plugs I should do
at the end of these videos,
but yeah, lots more to come.
We're working on lots of amazing videos
and I'm really excited to share them.
So I'll see you in the next one.
Bye, everyone.
Okay.